students at Eldorado High School in East
Las Vegas are getting a lesson in
political power good morning so our
community organizer Jasmine Villagomez
asks the diverse group of teenagers to
stand woman can you please sit down if
you are african-american can you please
sit down if you are Latino can you
please sit down
at the end there's only one boy left
standing y'all notice he's white
Villagomez reminds them of the long
struggle by women and people of color to
win the right to vote so many people
we're not eligible to participate in our
voting process it's an apt lesson in
Nevada the most diverse of the early
voting states its demographic makeup now
foretells what the US will look like in
the future so if you project forward and
you look at the share of
african-american Latino Asian Pacific
Islanders and you project out to you
know mid 21st century the profile
actually matches very closely tens of
thousands of Nevada residents have
already cast ballots in early voting get
out and vote get out no matter how long
the wait the lines are just do it I'm
here just to vote the trauma cult this
diverse electorate is the key to victory
in the caucuses all of the Democratic
candidates are working hard to harvest
votes from Nevada's diverse communities
some are doing better than others Peak
Budaj edge and Amy Klobuchar have so far
attracted little interest among voters
of color Elizabeth Warren has done
somewhat better President Joe Biden
courted the large Asian American voting
bloc with a campaign event in Las Vegas
Chinatown we choose compassion over
cruelty Bernie Sanders has made major
inroads among Latinos helped by a small
army of enthusiastic volunteers
[Applause]
Sanders is leading in the polls my
prediction is like whoever is doing a
better job on making sure that they
Latinos are engaged that's what's going
to win their vote back at Eldorado High
students are handing in completed voter
registration forms an act of civil
engagement and perhaps a commitment that
may last a lifetime rob reynolds al
jazeera Las Vegas